de toute façon ce sera compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre et de toute façon ce
sera politiquement complètement casse
gueule tant qu'on vaccine à la vitesse
de l'escargot
moi je ne crois pas qu'on puisse mettre
en place un pass impasse vaccinale ou
impasse sanitaires tant qu'on n'arrive
pas à vacciner et je pense que les gens
vont se révolter
en plus il va y avoir une espèce de
guerre des générations de permettre au
nonagénaire d'aller en boîte de nuit et
au restaurant et de l'interdire à la
jeunesse va être quelque chose de
problématique politiquement comme on le
disait avec fabrice à la veille d'une
présidentielle qui est tout sauf gagné
donc on va être face à une une une
double injonction terrible pour mac rond
et il va avoir la main qui tremble
il n'imaginait pas macron il ya quelques
quelques semaines encore que on le
démarrage vaccinale serait aussi
difficile
historiquement vous savez bien qu'il a
beaucoup contribué à l'élection à
l'arrivée de celui-là vanderlinden à à
la tête de l'union européenne dont qui
lui est aujourd'hui difficile de se
défausser sur la présidente de la
commission tout le monde sait dans le
monde politique que macro et et et
veyran n'y sont pas pour grand chose que
la responsabilité dans la gestion
catastrophique des contrats par la
présidente de la commission qui a voulu
s'en occuper alors qu'elle était
totalement incompétente sur ce sujet là
et qu'il n'y a pas de fonctionnaires qui
étaient habitués à passer ce type de
contrat très complexes que sont les
achats de médicaments ou les achats de
vaccins donc macron est complètement
coincés et ils n'osent pas attaqué
ursula von der laden donc il va
récupérer la mauvaise humeur des
français
c'est une situation qui est vraiment
vraiment très difficile le président
souffre beaucoup et ça ne va pas
favoriser une stratégie totalement
rationnelle sur ce passeport vaccinale
parce qu'en réalité le président est
piégé jamais il n'a imaginé qu'à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
il devrait faire face à un tel waterloo
vaccinale avec une opinion qui va finir
par craquer
[Musique]